- [Instructor] In a previous
video, we established
the entire solution set
for the following equation.
And we saw that all the x's
that can satisfy this equation
are a combination of these
x's and these x's here.
The reason why I'm
referring to each of them
as numerous xs is that for
any integer value of n,
you'll get another solution.
For any integer value of n,
What I wanna do in this video
is to make things a
little bit more concrete.
And the way that we're going
to do it is by exploring
all of the x values that
satisfy this equation
that sit in the closed interval
from negative pi over two to zero.
So I encourage you like always,
pause this video and have
a go at it by yourself
before we work through it together.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the first helpful thing is
we have these algebraic expressions.
We have things written in terms of pi.
Let's approximate them
all in terms of decimals.
So even pi over two, we
can approximate that.
Let's see, if pi is approximately 3.14,
half of that is approximately 1.57,
so we could say this is approximately
the closed interval from -1.57 to zero.
- 1.57 isn't exactly negative pi over two,
but it'll hopefully be suitable
for what we're trying to do here.
And now let's see if we can write
the different parts of these expressions,
or at least approximate them as decimals.
So this could be rewritten
as x is approximately,
if you were to take 1/8
times the inverse cosine
of -1/6, I encourage you to verify this
on your own on a calculator,
you would get that that's
approximately 0.22.
And then pi over four
is approximately 0.785.
So this expression would
be approximately 0.22
minus 0.785 times n,
where n could be any integer.
And then this one over here on the right,
let me do that in this yellow,
x could be approximately
equal to, well if this
evaluates to approximately 0.22,
then this is just the negative of it,
so it's going to be -0.22.
And then it's plus what approximately
pi over four is, so 0.785n.
And now what we could do
is just try different n's
and see if we're starting
above or below this interval,
and then see which of
the x values actually
fall in this interval.
So let's just start here.
If we just start at n equals zero,
actually why don't I set
up a little table here,
we have n here and if we
have the x value here,
when n is zero, well, then
you don't see this term,
and you just get approximately 0.22.
Now let's compare that to the interval.
The upper bound of that interval is zero.
So this does not sit in the interval.
So this is too high and we would want to
define the x's that sit in the interval.
We wanna find lower values.
So it's good that here, where
you're subtracting 0.785,
so I would use positive
integer values of n
to decrease this 0.22 here.
So when n equals one, we would
subtract 0.785 from that,
and I'll round all of these
to the hundredths place,
and that would get us to -0.57,
and that does sit in the interval.
So this looks good.
So this would be a solution
in that interval right over here.
And let's try n equals two.
So we would subtract 0.785 again,
and that would get us to -1.35,
not 25, 35, and that also
sits in the interval.
It's larger than -1.57,
so that looks good.
Let's subtract 0.785
again, when n equals three,
that would get us -2.14.
Well, that's all of a
sudden out of the interval
because that's below the lower bound here.
So this is too low.
So using this expression,
we've been able to find
two x values that sit in the
interval that we care about.
Now let's use these x
values right over here
and I'll set up another table.
So, let's see we have our n
and then we have our x values.
So let's start with n equals
zero 'cause that's easy
to compute, and then
this term would go away,
and we'd have -0.22, and that's actually
in this interval here, it's below zero,
it's larger than -1.57,
so that one checks out.
But now to really explore, we
have to go in both directions.
We have to increase it or decrease it.
So if we wanted to increase it,
we could have a situation
where n equals one.
So if n equals one, we're
gonna add 0.785 to this.
Now you immediately know
that that's going to be
a positive value, if you
computed it, it'd be 0.57,
which is larger than
zero, so this is too high.
So now we could try going lower than -0.22
by having negative values of n.
So if n is equal to -1, that
means we're subtracting 0.785
from this right over here
which would get us to -1.01.
Well, that one works out,
so that's in our interval.
And now let's subtract 0.785 again.
So I'll have n equals -2.
And so if I subtract 0.785 again,
I could round that to -1.79,
which is lower than -1.57,
so it's out of our
interval, so it's too low.
So all of the x values
that are in our interval
that satisfy this equation
are these two right over here.
And this one and this one,
and we are done.